[Music]
on this tuesday night the abhorrent
treatment of an indigenous woman
just before she died vile comments from
hospital staff caught on video
the demands for accountability this is
the norm
that's the problem presidential debate
night in america what to expect from the
first face-off between donald trump
and joe biden why do the majority of
canadians who have kovit 19
not know where they got it we don't know
it's actually safe or not
plus the new device that claims to
detect if the virus is circulating
in the air around you
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a disturbing story
about the treatment of a woman in a
quebec hospital
she recorded video of staff making
racist and callous remarks about her
while she lay in bed pleading for help a
short time later she died
joyce eshequan an indigenous woman
started recording on facebook live as
she listened to staff insult her
call her stupid and question her life
choices
tonight outside the hospital in joliet
where she died there is
outrage people have gathered to demand
an explanation and to honor her memory
and the call for answers has reached the
highest levels
what happened is totally unacceptable
there will be an inquiry two inquiries
in fact
and the uh the nurses
did something unacceptable and she has
been fired
there are lots of questions including
whether she was denied medical treatment
and whether this is part of a pattern of
behavior
at that hospital we're going to play
portions of the video
had eshequan not recorded it just before
she died
her story likely would have gone
unnoticed felicia perillo has our top
story tonight
tied to a hospital bed in the moments
before she passed away
joyce eshequan pleaded for help
instead she received shocking and racist
remarks
from hospital staff
what
thirty-seven-year-old eshequan was
brought to a hospital in joliet quebec
on saturday by ambulance
on monday while in crisis she started
recording live on facebook
there are reports that she suffered from
heart issues and had a reaction to
morphine she was given
the mother of seven died soon after
quebec's coroner's office announced
it will investigate the circumstances
surrounding her death
members of the etiquette community that
eshequan was part of
gathered to mourn
a community band council member said
there needs to be justice
for joyce reaction to the incident was
swift during a press conference on
tuesday quebec premier francois lego
denounced the incident
saying a nurse has been fired and two
different investigations are
underway but when asked if this was an
example of systemic racism in quebec
he denied that existed i really don't
think
that we have this kind
of way of dealing with
first nation people in our hospitals in
quebec
but some beg to differ the executive
director of the
native women's shelter in montreal says
discrimination against indigenous
peoples in the province
is present and needs to be addressed
quickly
this is the norm that's the problem
and it's only when it's recorded that
everyone gets to see it
but it's you know if you're not lucky
enough to have a cell phone
to record it then you know does it
happen multiple vigils and
demonstrations are planned in honor of
eshequan
including a protest in montreal on
saturday
felicia parilla global news juliette
quebec
nova scotia's premier has apologized to
victims of systemic racism in that
province and
unveiled what is called a restorative
plan to reform policing and public
safety
stephen mcneil said a brave and bold
approach is necessary to combat the
inequality black
indigenous and other people of color
have experienced in the justice system
the current system is broken and the
only way to fix it
is to find a better way a more just way
imagine that black mother not needing to
warn her children when they go outside
instead encouraging them to have fun
and be who they are let's not imagine it
anymore mcneil is establishing an
independent team made up of members of
the african
nova scotian and migma communities plus
police agencies
experts and government officials it will
assess what reforms are needed and
recommend government
action consultations will take place
over the next 12 to 18 months which is
longer than mcneil may be in office
he announced his resignation last month
saying he would stay on as premier until
the nova scotia liberal party
picks a new leader now to covet 19 and
new
efforts to try to clear the backlog of
tests and reduce the lineups
the federal government says it has
struck a deal to buy nearly 8 million
rapid tests for use in canada the test
is called
id now it's made by abbott industries in
the united states
it claims to process results on the spot
in less than 15 minutes
right now many canadians have to wait
days for covet 19 test results
there's a problem though this new rapid
test has not been approved by health
canada
and as michael couture explains it's
unclear when it will be
the federal government wants to be able
to test up to 200
000 canadians per day for covid19
backlogs across the country mean on
average we've only been able to test
71 000 people daily over the last week
so you're waiting hours to get tested
and waiting up to seven days for results
the powerful point-of-care molecular
instrument
that is ideally suited for use on the
front lines enter
the abbott id now the american-made test
can turn around a result in 15 minutes
and is being widely used throughout the
united states
our government announced it has secured
up to 7.9
million tests we have pursued an
advanced
purchase agreement to secure canada's
access to these tests
conditional on health canada regulatory
approval
that lack of approval means they won't
help ease the long lines across the
country just yet
and canada's top doctor says the tests
may be most effective
in remote areas to areas where
you can't sort of send
your samples without a really long
turnaround time to
and you have to fly your samples for
example dr teresa tam did add those
tests could help in high exposure areas
where you need a quick turnaround on
results but there have also been
issues with the id now test the u.s food
and drug administration has received
dozens of reports of false negatives the
high-risk bee cube has been approved by
our health agency but there is no
purchase agreement
it's why the conservatives say the
liberals have dropped the ball
we're in a race to get these
technologies there are many other
countries around the world
that are trying to procure them that are
trying to manufacture them that are
trying to develop them
the health minister contends the
government is working flat out on this
file
we have also accelerated our processes
at health canada to make sure that as
new technology arrives
we are well placed to approve it we have
doubled our regulatory
capacity despite that since march health
canada has only approved
three point-of-care testing devices one
of which
is for research purposes only donna
okay mike likature in ottawa thank you
the federal covet alert app
now has another province on board quebec
which had rejected the technology now
says it is ready to sign on and the app
will be live in quebec
in the coming days provinces have been
slow to adopt the app since it first
rolled out in
ontario in late july bc alberta pei nova
scotia and the territories still have
not signed on
manitoba said yesterday it's ready to
join and that the app will be active
there
in the next week there are now so many
new covet 19
cases being reported every day in canada
we've reached the peak we saw in april
here's the picture across the country
quebec is reporting almost 800 new cases
today the most of any province
in ontario there are 554 new cases a dip
from yesterday's record
of 700. out west alberta has 160 new
cases today in bc
105.
the fact that cases are now at the same
level as during the initial peak is
worrisome
things have escalated quickly and they
can escalate further
unless we all work together to slow the
spread of the virus
we have heard that message on repeat
that we must limit the number of people
we come into contact with
in fact the majority of canadians who
have covid19 now
don't know where they got it that makes
limiting its spread more difficult
abigail beeman looks at what we do know
and why more information is vital for
contact tracing
in ottawa a new tool shows you where
covet 19
cases are by neighborhood by being able
to observe
these differences at a neighborhood
level and see which neighborhoods are
most affected by the pandemic
we can really sort of focus our
resources
but it can't tell you where people
caught the virus
and nationally the latest public health
data shows
58 percent of cases came from an unknown
source
that is telling us that perhaps there's
more community transmission and hidden
chains of transmission you don't want
that
ottawa says they've given billions to
the provinces to improve data systems
even lent ontario 1500 federal contact
tracers
to get that number down but we don't
know whether it's safer to go to the gym
than a restaurant
to a private backyard gathering or have
a drink on a patio
people would like to know exactly which
activities or
behavior i should avoid based on what is
the most problematic
there's not such a fine line we don't
know what's actually safe or not
experts say we may never know in part
because people have so many more
contacts now
than in the spring i want to see schools
open and i want to see other businesses
which
we need stay open and i want to see
businesses which have been shut for
three or f
three or four months stay open we can
start by targeting things
which won't have huge economic
ramifications and that would be social
gatherings
the most important thing to know is that
you get
kovid 19 from people
not from places in quebec as some areas
face a new lockdown
many places are closing libraries and
movie theaters for example
while malls and gyms stay open they're
trying to understand exactly
why the government is closing down some
businesses
and keeping others open but we are
honestly unable
to answer there's a systematic
lack of transparency i would like to
have this data
perfectly which is not the case it's
always
estimate quebec's lockdown begins
thursday
abigail b ben global news ottawa
we have a clearer picture tonight about
the financial fallout from covid19 and a
warning the pandemic could have a
permanent
impact on the canadian economy the
parliamentary budget office says the
federal deficit for 2020 is on track to
be more than
328 billion dollars relative to the size
of the economy the deficit amounts to 15
percent of the gross domestic product
that's by far the largest the country
has seen in over 50 years
much of the spending is on emergency aid
to support businesses and individuals
and
is expected to be temporary the pbo
projects the budget deficit will fall to
about 74 billion dollars
next year canada and the uk are imposing
sanctions on the man who claims to be
president of belarus and 10 other
government officials there the measures
include freezing assets and barring them
from entering canada
widespread protests and violent
government arrests have gripped the
country since the presidential election
52 days ago
which canada calls illegitimate foreign
affairs minister francois philippe
champagne says belarus is committing
systematic
human rights violations and shows no
indication of being genuinely committed
to finding a negotiated solution with
opposition groups
the opposition leader of belarus who is
in exile in lithuania
met with the french president emmanuel
macron today macron is promising to work
on securing the release of political
prisoners
in belarus president trump and
democratic nominee joe biden will face
each other tonight on stage in cleveland
ohio and in front of millions of
americans watching on tv
it is the first u.s presidential debate
of 2020
90 minutes with no commercials trump who
is 74 and biden who is 77
will be scrutinized as much for how they
perform
as the substance of what they say
jackson proskow our washington bureau
chief is with me jackson
given what we know about these two men
what strategies can we expect
hi donna well there's good reason to
expect that donald trump will go on the
attack against joe biden pretty much
from the outset tonight remember he
already got himself impeached over
going after joe biden's son hunter biden
that doesn't mean the topic is off
limits tonight in fact we expect to hear
that a fair bit
this evening there's also a sense that
trump will broadly attack
biden's record in washington his many
many years in public service in this
country
and really try and paint him as sort of
a gateway to extremism
on the left joe biden faces a double
barrel challenge here on one hand he's
expected to go after trump
for what he has consistently called a
failure of leadership over issues like
the
pandemic which has killed 200 000
americans
on the other hand he has to avoid
getting dragged into the fray and really
has to try and paint himself as a
capable competent statesman
a safe choice especially for republicans
who might not be comfortable voting for
trump
jackson these presidential debates are
rarely game changers for voters what do
the polls indicate
about how many undecided voters there
are and and how many might be swayed by
what they hear tonight
yeah keep in mind there are six topics
for tonight's debate and they're things
like the pandemic and the economy and
race relations
in this country and voters certainly
care about those issues but they care
far more about the issue of whether or
not donald trump is president
and an astonishing 90 percent of voters
according to polls
have already made up their mind about
who they're voting for there's not a lot
of room to pick up new supporters
tonight
although arguably both men will be
trying to do that really the polls have
been consistent in biden's favor he's
maintained a six to eight point lead
for three or four months now those
numbers haven't budged donna
voters are really locked in at this
point i'm always skeptical of the polls
though especially after last time and
jackson
this campaign and this whole year has
been flooded with misinformation
conspiracy theories lies and stuff is
spreading about this debate
before it's even started tell us about
that yeah these are rumors that tend to
come up around
every debate but they're specific to
this one in the sense that donald trump
has put a lot of effort into claiming
that joe biden is in some sort of mental
decline that of course is a baseless
conspiracy theory
but now it seems like the trump campaign
is worried that biden might actually
perform well this evening so they're
spreading the rumor that
perhaps he's taking
performance-enhancing drugs or wearing
some sort of earpiece to feed him in the
answers
donna that is all baseless but it gives
you a sense of the information war
that's going to surround an event that
has a super bowl sized audience
all right we will be watching jackson
prosco in washington thanks
another province is having a pandemic
election coming up
what's at stake in saskatchewan
voters in saskatchewan are heading to
the polls on october 26th
it's the third province to hold an
election in the midst of the pandemic
premier scott mo took over the
leadership of the saskatchewan party
from brad wall in 2018 so this will be
his first crack
at getting elected as premier ryan
kessler is with me from saskatoon ryan
what kind of campaign
is expected donna the governing
saskatchewan party is asking voters who
they trust to lead the economic recovery
coming out of the covet 19 pandemic
as you mentioned it's scott moe's first
race as leader but he's relying on his
party's track record over the course of
the last 13 years
while attacking the opposition ndp
according to mo the sask party has
the right plan to make life more
affordable in saskatchewan while
balancing the budget by 2024.
he says the province's ndp and leader
ryan miley would go on a spending spree
if elected
he wants to spend with no no plan of
balance no plan to grow
the economy here in the province which
ultimately means
that there will be cuts at some time in
the future when this type of reckless
spending
is allowed to to occur of the
legislature's 61 seats 46 are held by
the sask party
13 belong to the new democrats and two
are vacant
the ndp is positioning itself as the
party that will invest in the people
files
such as education and health care the
ndp's tone is similar to what it was
during the 2016 election
accusing the sask party of planning cuts
instead of investments
and if they're re-elected it will only
be worse austerity
on steroids on day one of this campaign
both parties were light on platform
specifics but heavy on political
rhetoric
there's still plenty of time for those
details before voters head to the polls
with pandemic precautions on october
26th
donna all right ryan kessler in
saskatoon tonight thanks
virus detector next the canadian
technology putting hope
in the air
a company in southwestern ontario claims
to have developed game-changing
technology in the fight against covet
19.
it's designed a wall-mounted device that
looks similar to a carbon monoxide
detector
it scans the air for covet 19 particles
the devices
aren't in use yet they're still in the
testing phase and they're not cheap the
cost is about twelve thousand dollars
each
jeff semple explains how they work and
how they could one day
be put to use the pandemic is a fight
against an invisible
enemy but what if there was a way to
detect kovid 19
lurking inside a classroom or on a train
an ontario company claims they've
developed a tool to do
just that we feel very good about you
know being part of the solution
paul gezi's company specializes in
indoor air quality
they're tech typically used to check for
dangerous gases in industrial facilities
but when covet 19 struck gezzy wondered
if their tools could be repurposed
for the pandemic could we look for covid
like we do for air quality
they developed this wall-mounted device
called biocloud
placed in a classroom for example or any
space up to a thousand square feet
gesi says a built-in fan sucks up all
the air in the room
multiple times in an hour which is then
instantly analyzed
we believe our technology will flag and
alert for kovid
and then you can properly test each
individual lab tests at this ontario
university
found the biocloud device could quickly
and effectively detect an array of
airborne pathogens
including the virus that causes covid19
there's absolutely huge potential for
this type of technology
similar tech is being developed around
the world to detect covid19 in the air
or in a patient's breath
while experts debate to what extent the
virus is airborne
studies show it can linger in a poorly
ventilated room
for hours but if they're in the
classroom for like three to six hours at
a time
with no ventilation eventually wherever
you disperse it that virus will build up
and build up and build up
but pulling a virus out of thin air is
tricky
covet 19 is fragile and looks similar to
other virus particles
i was quite happy uh to see actually
this new technology coming up
but as a scientist uh then the questions
start coming up you know
what is the level of sensitivity how
selective is
the device against just this particular
virus the noble coronavirus
and at this point we don't know bio
clouds technology is a trade secret but
it's now being reviewed by the canadian
government
and the company hopes to start selling
to customers around the world
by november jeff semple global news
toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is fraser's grove park in
winnipeg
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye